the Joe Rogan experience when I'm going
on a tour of the Vatican I had a really
great guide it was really cool he took
my family through this thing and he was
he was a professor and he was really
happy that I was so curious about things
so and so whoever wandering around
billions of dollars of stolen art and
one of the things I kept saying I go by
other penis is so small like what's
going on with that and he was like
that's a really important question and
he's like back then the thought was that
bigger penises were brutish and that
they were that these you know you got to
realize these are people that were
fending off barbarians and the idea was
that their gods would be beautifully
proportioned but they would have these
small sort of less dangerous penises
it's very nice yeah yeah they would they
would make them like that on purpose
they were all they all had little dicks
all of them and I'm like these guys like
if you looked at these guys like just
the way they were built
yeah the reality is most of them would
have hogs hmm right these are heavily
muscled Jannik thick men with a lot of
testosterone they would have big dicks
most likely right that's the reason why
women find that build attractive
probably other than the fact that it's
gonna be the person who'd be more
successful at protecting you from said
barbarians well I think is it true that
the castrati of Italy were sought after
as lovers they could still perform
really yeah but then you didn't need to
worry about pregnancy how could they
could get erect yeah when they were
castrate that doesn't mean any sense
they're wrong
yeah I don't think that's correct I
think they're eunuchs I think that's why
they would do that to men I mean men who
would work in castles and they would
have eunuchs that would work with the
Queen I guess they could leave well I
don't know what what the definite what
operation was performed on the castrati
there was a dosterone okay but I
believed that there was a way in which
they were sought after as lovers maybe
that's
probably what it is what just kind of
Lingus yeah I actually think that they
were able to set I'm not sure what
operation was done but I believe that
they were able to sexually perform in a
conventional way Jamie and if you could
find the plural for penis that's got a
Pinay yeah yeah
penises just sounds so [ __ ] crude
[Laughter]
well dicks is real that's the right way
to say it
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] yeah you don't say
[ __ ] I might start castrati we're also
supposed to be great lovers they could
last long says toe masini
to say that name Montez squeak how do
you say that - montes Montez squee men's
squad they would have inspired a taste
for Gomorrah
in people whose taste is the least
depraved but
and when Casanova fell in love with a
castrato who conveniently turned out to
be a woman in drag he asked her to dress
as a castrato in bed okay I'm done check
please for those women for those women
who choose as dried and put it - in
quotes in soft UNIX place their bliss
and shun the scrubbing of a bearded kiss
yeah they wanted someone who eats a lot
of [ __ ] affairs were idolized and safe
but bed-hopping could be risky for the
castrati one was assassinated by his
lovers furious family and another who
wrote to the Pope requesting permission
to marry on the basis of that his
castration had been ineffective received
the reply let him be castrated better
the Pope said no he can't get married
we're gonna cut your nuts off better
gonna do a better job all mouth and no
trousers castrati had more fun than you
could thank hello Guardian great [ __ ]
Samantha Ellis meets a singer who wishes
he'd had the chop oh yeah
see this might just be a story you know
I mean the guy says I regret not having
been castrated they go get cast right
here something crazy but that's that's
one of those things where that's
that might be a story like a good way to
write something maybe no and click
Beatty and it's been around for a long
time
here's a we may not know the last
castrato was recorded see there's
actually a requirement played it's about
a dozen times yeah yeah it's pretty
gross it's not good he wasn't a talented
one well that's not what's gross what's
gross is the thought that this was a
child that was taken and castrated and
then for me to live this life look it's
it's absolutely ridiculous but getting
back to Michael Jackson I think there is
is that right yeah Alessandro Mora
chechi more set more ski more SG more SG
Alessandro more SG the last castrato
Christ the complete Vatican recordings
what did they do that man's mouth
[Applause]